محمود مدينه اوكرانيه تعاني من ضربات
المدفعيه الروسيه وذلك منذ عده اشهر هنا
على خط الجبهه الشوارع ومهجوره تعيش مئات
العائلات الاوكرانيه في اقبيه مع اطفالهم
الذي يبلغ من العمر 14 عاما والذي لا يريد
مغادره المدينه على الرغم من انعدام الامن
فيها
تحب هذه المدينه
واذا كان لدي صديق واحد على الاقل سيكون
الامر ممتعا
الاطفال الذين بقوا في المدينه معرضون
للخطر يوميا ويختبئون بعيدا في قول احدى
المدارس جريجوري الذي يبلغ من العمر 13
عاما يذهب يوميا الى منزله لتناول الغداء
ثم يعود الى القبر
عندما اكون في المنزل
فقد قتل مدنيان في الايام الاخيره في نفس
هذا الطريق
نعيش هو بدون ماء ولا كهرباء ولا تدفئه
ولا انترنت
معظم الاشخاص عاطلون عن العمل كالعاده
يقتل الناس يوميا
الضغوط المستمر التي يعاني منها الاطفال
قد تؤدي الى اصابتهم واضطرابات عقليه على
المدى الطويل